what is Britain doing in this era we
tried to LEAP out of the EU in 2016 and
have had years of contortions since the
attempt to sort of reverse decline keeps
running into a block or a wall if you
ask a politician in America at what they
want to do on the left they'll say they
want social justice and so on on the
right they'll say they want to build the
economy
well I mean I happen to think that the
latter is more plausible and a better
answer but they have a plan which is the
American economy should be going
gangbusters what is the plan in Britain
exactly
I mean do any of them know the concierma
give a applausible explanation of what
the country would do under his
leadership uh
can Richie soon act to that can he
actually say what his vision of Britain
is I I think the answer is no and and
that there's something very revealing
and